[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
singular value decomposition and what
we're now going to talk about is how to
choose the truncation value of the
number of modes to keep for the SVD so
we're going to talk about the SVD and
truncation and this is one of the most
important issues that anyone using the
SVD will have to face is that when you
have x equals u Sigma V transpose
remember we can choose to keep only the
first are columns of U are columns of V
and R by R sub matrix of V which we're
gonna denote either by u tilde sigma
tilde v tilde transpose sometimes i
didn't know if this with a little
subscript R to denote that it's rank R
you either use Tilda's or ours but how
do you choose so how to choose R this is
one of the most fundamental questions in
the SVD and there are all kinds of
heuristics and rules of thumb to do this
so I'm just going to show you a number
of them oftentimes what you'll do is
you'll plot the log of the singular
values in the diagonal of Sigma so
you'll plot the log of Sigma J versus J
and you hope that your distribution
looks you know something like that where
there's some really really energetic
singular values and then some that are
really small and so what people often do
is they'll pick this rank R by
identifying something like an elbow
where that goes from being high energy
to low energy high variance to low
variance sometimes so this is an elbow
or a knee sometimes you'll pick R so
that you capture 90 or 95 or 99% of the
energy in this so you'll basically pick
R so that everything above this R is 99%
of the distribution and everything below
is only 1% so sometimes you'll do it
based on the percentage of variance or
energy explained
I would argue that these are very
heuristic and they don't work that well
unless you have a really really clean
sharp drop-off in your singular values
okay and so there is a fantastic paper
by gavage and Donahoe that I want to
point you towards which essentially
comes up with an optimal way to truncate
an optimal rank are to truncate given
some assumptions on the type of data you
have okay so this is a paper by gavage
and Donahoe it's one of my favorite
papers in the last few years I think
this is a 2014 I Triple E transactions
on information info theory I believe
it's volume 60 issue 8 okay so you can
find this this paper it's an excellent
excellent paper and it gives conditions
on how to choose the optimal ranked to
truncate your SVD and remember you know
we want to truncate this SVD because we
want to have as few modes given by the
columns of U and V as possible to
describe the data in X and so if I can
get away with you know finding five
informative columns of U and V as
opposed to 500 that would be great so I
want our so there's always this balance
and modeling between complexity and kind
of accuracy okay if I have more rank R
I'll have a more accurate but more
complex model if I have lower rank R
I'll have a less accurate but less
complex model and so we're looking for
this sweet spot where we get the most of
the information and X but without kind
of overfitting to maybe the noise in X
or some of the little features we don't
care about okay and that's kind of what
what they are getting at here and I'm
not going to walk you through all of the
math of their derivation their paper is
fantastic it's easy to read and they
have code online so you can you can work
it out yourself it's in section 1.7 of
our book also so this is section 1.7 of
our book data-driven science and
airing the link will be in the comments
what I really want to do now is I want
to just give you a feeling for how this
gavage Donahoe optimal hard threshold
thing works okay and their entire
premise is that your data X can be
written as the sum of kind of a true low
rank data signal I'm going to call that
X true plus X noise and more importantly
let's let's put a little gamma out here
okay so X noise is going to be assumed
to be zero mean variance one normally
distributed okay so it's Gaussian noise
0 mean unit variance multiplied by this
gamma so you can be large or small
depending on the magnitude of this gamma
okay and so the observation is that for
lots and lots of high dimensional data
I'm gonna draw some pictures here if we
we actually can compute analytically
what the SVD of a noise matrix would
look like the SVD of a noise matrix
looks kind of like that yeah this is the
log Sigma versus J and what Gavin
Donahoe realized was that lots and lots
of data if you take its SVD actually
looks a lot like this it looks like this
and then at some point it deviates in
the large singular values okay and so
what they what they essentially are
doing is saying anything that is larger
than the noise floor from the the SVD of
the noise matrix everything above here
is signal and everything below here is
noise and should be truncated and that's
precisely how they find this optimal
rank are to truncate the SVD and they go
on to actually prove that if your data
really does have low rank structure and
a Gaussian noise matrix added to it then
what you want to do is you want to find
the
first singular value that's larger than
the biggest singular value of your noise
matrix and you want to keep all of those
singular values and truncate everything
that is smaller than than the noise
floor okay
so it's a very very intuitive
common-sense thing to do is that you
define a noise floor given by the max
Sigma of your noise matrix and you only
keep the terms in your in your SVD of
your your corrupted noisy measurement
matrix X that are above that noise floor
so that determines the rank R it's only
the singular values that are larger than
some hard threshold value above this
noise floor okay pretty cool and what
they do is they actually show some
different cases where you can use this
so let's say for example I have case one
is pretty simple let's say X is square
and gamma is known this is the least
likely case in reality right you don't
usually have a square matrix X and you
don't usually know how much noise you
have but let's say for for now you you
have a square X and you know gamma what
we're gonna do is we're gonna truncate
all Sigma lower than some threshold
value tau and this tau is going to be
determined by these by these values here
okay so if X is square and gamma is
known then tau is equal to 4 over the
square root of 3 times gamma times root
n ok this is a very nice compact this is
not an easy formula to derive but it's a
beautiful compact formula in terms of n
the dimension of your matrix X if it's a
square n by n matrix gamma the amount of
noise if you if you actually know how
much noise there is and this factor 4
over root 3 any singular value that's
larger than that you keep any that's
smaller than that you truncate and it
looks like this okay
but what's I think really really useful
about this is that they go on to solve
the case where X is rectangular and we
don't know gamma we just have a noisy
matrix but we don't know how much noise
so gamma unknown and in this case they
have a really clever approach where
essentially what they do is they all
they have is measurements of a singular
value distribution that maybe looks like
that and so what they do is they take
the median singular value Sigma median
and from that median singular value and
the aspect ratio the shape of this
rectangular matrix we're going to call
that beta is kind of n divided by M or M
divided by n depending on what size the
matrix is so based on this median
singular value and this aspect ratio of
this rectangular matrix they can infer
kind of the best fit noise distribution
that's consistent assuming that this
median singular value is in the noise
floor which is a good assumption if I
have enough data then they can again
infer what the max singular value of
this red noise distribution is and
determine what this tau 2 threshold is
to give us this optimal rank R okay and
the formula is a little bit involved I'm
not going to reproduce the whole thing
but here we have tau equals some Omega
of beta times the median singular value
where this is essentially a correction
factor for the aspect ratio of the
matrix and this is a pretty involved
expression it's a little bit nasty to
write down it's in their paper and they
have a nice MATLAB code to actually
compute this but what what you need to
know is that if you have data that has
structure and noise even if you don't
know how much noise is added you can
estimate it from that median singular
value and then you can infer what this
optimal tau is where you would threshold
singular values below that tau to give
you your optimal rank
R
okay so I'm gonna code this up in a
couple of examples we're gonna do one
matrix where it's exactly this it's a
low rank structure plus a white noise
matrix and we're going to show that this
works really really well and then I'm
also going to show you this on the
eigenfaces data set where it's not at
all obvious that it can be written like
this I mean it's not like there's
Gaussian noise on top of the low ranked
face structure but even in real world
data this still gives a very very good
approximation for where to truncate to
get meaningful features so I'm going to
show you that in two examples in the
next lectures thank you